Sarah foster opens up about Kate  Hudson's dating life I was a guy I  definitely wanted a cake now Paige told  us that she got set up the other day  with JJ why does it happen to her a lot  like her people always trying to set her  up did she tell you the holiday I mean I  think a lot of guys are interested in  dating tape that was a guy I definitely  wanted a cave it's not that hard to  believe  do people set her up though like are  they just oh yeah people work what about  you have you set her up  I know I've never set her up know what  kind of guy would you want to see her  with what kind of guy deserts me okay  it's like a traditional a traditional  girl if she really likes you know she  loves cooking she loves stay home when  she's in love she's she's home I think  people think of her this like larger  than life out on the town you know but  she's like very simple  she's very simple she wants like a  simple a nice life she does she wants to